the Joe Rogan experience David Seaman
who's on the podcast last week had a
really interesting take on Bitcoin that
I thought was kind of funny he was
saying that if if like Bank of America
for say if they were smart that they
would get involved in Bitcoin he was
like you already have this established
name brand like cryptocurrencies are
gonna be here they're there they're here
to stay
this is his take he's like why wouldn't
you capitalize on the name brand that
you've already built in on and getting
on the mark and quick get in on it now
in the early days and established like
that Bank of America like still has like
a footing in in this as well
as in regular money and he was like it
would be a really wise investment I
think you're gonna see that happening in
short time really we saw this with the
Internet which was at first the
telecommunications companies fought
tooth and nail they could not believe
that a decentralized packet switch
network like the internet would deliver
quality voice and quality video they
wanted to build highly controlled and
structured networks and they tried to
fight it because it threatened the
long-distance market which was very
lucrative it threatened many other
markets today three-quarters of all
international calls have known skype 3/4
3/4 that's that's a market that a few
you know a two decades ago was 15 20
billion dollar market and disappeared
and essentially they had to restructure
operations now they made up for it the
smart ones became very good as Internet
service providers and created whole new
businesses that replace those lost
revenues so so what happened there is
you have these telecom companies trying
to fight it until some of the smaller
ones some of the ones that don't have
solid entrenched positions and can't
take advantage of size think you know
what I mean I'm gonna cut off from this
herd and go play with that Bitcoin a bit
and as soon as that starts happening
there's almost a stampede because
everybody tries to rush into it that's
what happens with telecommunications the
smaller providers started peeling off
from the herd and instead of fighting it
they started trying to build service
providers so it's really just a matter
who runs first right someone's gonna
start running and then right and then
the herd breaks apart because until the
first one breaks everyone's like wow
we're too serious for this Bitcoin stuff
and they're looking over their shoulder
trying to make sure that everybody else
is also staying away from it but
eventually the market dynamic changes so
it's just essentially it's just human
nature like with human nature there's
two certain rules that are just always
going to be into place play hard-to-get
and follow leader those are two big ones
yeah and Bitcoin threatens some business
structures within the banking industry
admits gonna make it difficult for them
to charge exorbitant fees to do
international wire transfers when you
can do it cheaper just like if you have
Skype you can't justify three dollars a
minute long-distance calls
right and but at the same time the smart
banker is looking at this and their
thing yeah but if we have a cheap
efficient secure payment system we can
build some really interesting things on
top of that and creates whole new
businesses that are very competitive
that can actually give us a lead so we
outrun the herd the you know disruption
in a competitive market is actually very
very enticing to the to the second and
third tier players because they don't
have an advantage they're too small to
compete against the big guys but if they
see this disruptive technology I think
well maybe if I hitch a ride on that I'm
gonna overtake everybody and you know I
can be the blockbuster or I can be the
Netflix I can be the Tower Records or I
can be the iTunes and we've seen this
happen in technology races before yeah
that's fascinating
how people some people just don't want
to buck the trends they do they don't
want to go along with the flow of things
or they want to buck the trends they
want to somehow or another figure out a
way where you know they can prove
everybody else wrong and VHS is making a
comeback and you know renting movies is
still valid you know there's there's a
lot of those fuckers out there that just
won't let it go radio companies change
is scary yeah it is scary but that's
that's that's the nature of the beast
especially today we were involved in the
craziest time for change the world has
ever known
yeah um there are at the moments being
on the top of an industry especially an
industry that's involved in technology
is a very precarious position you know
if you talk to Kodak a decade ago do you
think they would they would realize that
suddenly the largest vendor or
manufacturer of cameras in the world
would be a telephone company nokia nokia
within three years became the world's
largest maker of cameras and suddenly
the entire industry changed right and
how do you compete against that they're
not even in your industry they just came
out of left field it's like you're
suddenly the horse buggy manufacturer
and Ford is taking your business and you
never expected that was gonna happen
well nokia has a camera phone now a
Windows Phone that is some insane amount
of pixels it's like 40 fucking
megapixels or something some crate 41 41
megapixel says Jamie Jamie's on top of
that shit
41 fucking megapixels on a phone I mean
this thing I think has of the note 3 I
think it that's 12 or something no it's
better than that you familiar with
Moore's law yes so so for your listeners
too Moore's law it was created by Gordon
more processors right processing speed
and yeah and what he said was that he
estimated because of the way silicon
works every 18 months the speed of a
computer would double or the price would
drop by half and that has been true now
for more than 25 years and and that
thing then plays out in camera
megapixels in storage on SD cards in the
size of the of your smartphone in the
number of sensors you can put into the
smartphone and it's battery battery life
is the one that's lagging behind and
it's the main thing that's holding back
this technology Moore's law also applies
to things like Bitcoin it also applies
to networks like the internet and what
it means is that if you're in an
industry that's established then
suddenly you have a competitor that's
coming at you with the power of Moore's
law you know better watch out because
you're in
it's not a matter of whether you will be
able to compete in a decade it's a
matter of whether your industry will
still exist in a decade right right yeah
that fascinating that whole industries
can just vanish 150 years of Kodak and
then suddenly film doesn't exist God in
the decade do you remember when you used
to have to pay money for a long distance
you know long distance calls don't exist
like you didn't call New York right now
on your home phone it's regular call on
your cell phone it's totally normal like
if you used to call long distance on a
cell phone it was an exorbitant amount
of money Saturday afternoons London
payphone when I was a student I would go
there with a stack of coins that was
probably about $10 worth in today's
money I would sit in a payphone and my
family would know what time I was gonna
call coordinated I'd call in they'd be a
line of 15 relatives sitting standing
behind the phone on the 8th and side nav
hi mom
I love you very much hi dad I love you
very much hey sis it's all awesome
okay next aunt aunt Maria Julie aunt WA
you know London's awesome and I'm
stuffing coins as fast as I can into
this payphone and then you know four or
five minutes later ten dollars down the
drain and I've said hello to the entire
family and that's all I could afford
Wow that was my experience and now you
could Skype for hours for free and not
crazy look at a video of each other
talking to each other through your
laptop for free Wow fascinating
fascinating times when you put it in
that kind of a perspective you really
sort of understand the change they just
the ability that we have to reach out to
each other it's just unprecedented in
human history it's never been even
remotely close to what it is now I saw
somebody walking down the street the
other day skyping with someone while
they were walking on the street and they
were talking while they were walking
down the street they like yeah so we're
gonna and then the other person on the
other end I'm looking at their phone I'm
like this is crazy they're doing it
through a cell phone connection I'm
doing that all the time now yeah walking
down the street through a cell phone
connection streaming video back and
forth to each other it's amazing amazing